[Musique]
y
John L
assassin
[Musique]
speee
spee
[Applaudissements] [Musique
]
pour aujourd'hui [Musique
imagine qu'il n'y a pas de
[Musique]
pays ouais
ouais maintenant
pour toujours je
t'aime
ouais
ouais maintenant
pour toujours,
c'est le premier film que j'ai fait après la
mort de John [Musique], j'aime et j'essaie de montrer dans ce
film euh toutes les choses que nous avons faites
ensemble, pas seulement John Lennon en tant que
pop star mais John Lenon en tant qu'homme  euh
et en tant que mari, en tant que père et aussi euh
juste une personne qui essaie de vivre dans sa
société
euh et de faire de son mieux
[Musique] [
Musique]
il
[Musique]
en 1968 quand John et moi
avons posé pour deux vierges qui  était une
pochette de disque et nous avons tous les deux posé nus
pour montrer notre nudité au monde et
euh 1980, c'était euh presque 12 ans après,
alors nous avons juste dit : eh bien, écoute,
montrons-le-leur, tu sais, nous avons l'air
bien, tu sais et euh, il y avait  ce
sentiment aussi mais quand j'ai commencé à monter
le film, j'ai vu que c'était vrai,
nous étions des tonnes et des tonnes à faire l'amour et
c'était très difficile à monter et je savais que
nous allions le montrer sur notre télé et
à quel point c'était difficile  c'est pour montrer l'amour
ou la nudité, donc j'ai été très prudent
et j'ai juste monté de telle manière qu'il
ne montre pas seulement nos visages, nos
épaules et nos bras, mais quand j'ai
fait ce film et euh,
je l'ai envoyé en Angleterre.  euh ils ont décidé
que c'était trop provocateur et ils
n'ont pas montré le
film qui avait été
tourné environ 2 semaines avant sa mort euh
dans le but que ce soit un film pour
accompagner une des
chansons donc
euh quand John et moi avons pris  ces images
et après nous l'avons vu à l'écran,
nous nous disions : eh bien, comment allons-nous
monter cela parce qu'il y en a tellement,
vous
savez, c'est presque comme si c'était mon
monde magique et je vous le montre maintenant
[Musique]
Je  Je pensais que c'était
New York depuis longtemps, c'est
avant
INE,
sinon ce serait comme une
publicité pour des cigarettes, vous savez, qui
s'allument toujours.
J'avais cette vision que tous ces
gens gris, en quelque sorte, se
tenaient là et sortaient comme ça, vous
savez et euh,
je viens de réaliser  que c'était le
visuel, tu sais, un jour de neige et tous ces
gens qui se tenaient là
et c'est une chanson que j'ai écrite il y a
environ 12 ans,
donc c'est juste incroyable, tu sais, je
ne sais pas vraiment ce qui se passe
parce que toutes ces visions que j'ai eues
probablement  ça parlait du futur mais qui
sait à l'époque je ne savais pas et quand
je reviens à toutes mes chansons toutes les chansons
euh j'aime presque à l'époque où
j'écrivais je ne savais pas et ça parlait
de mon avenir
donc
euh, c'est un peu effrayant dans ce
sens, eh bien, John n'était
pas John n'est pas mort parce qu'il
s'est suicidé ou il a été drogué ou
ou il a eu une crise cardiaque, non, Jo a été
tué et c'était très important pour moi
de montrer que le monde
et euh, que les gens
se souviennent parce que je pense que nous
sommes tous responsables de sa mort, mon ex bien
sûr, y compris
moi-même et John et moi avons toujours
essayé de créer un monde en paix et c'est
très ironique que Joan qui aimait
tant la paix soit morte dans un tel  d'une manière violente
jusqu'à ce que Joan meure d'une manière très étrange, je
pensais que j'avais une vie tout à fait normale
et euh, quand j'y repense, bien
sûr, je sais ce qui est normal, je ne
sais pas vraiment mais je veux dire, j'ai toujours pensé
que je  J'ai eu une vie normale et quand John est
mort, j'ai commencé à penser vraiment que c'était
trop, euh, je ne
pense pas que beaucoup de gens vivent ça, tu
sais et avant ça, je pensais que mon
problème, euh ou
mes euh, les choses qui se produisent dans ma vie
sont toutes des événements.  juste des choses humaines normales tu
sais avoir un enfant avoir un mari euh euh
avoir un appartement à New York
avoir une maison d'été à C Spring Harbor
tout ce genre de choses c'est tout à fait
normal et nous étions euh
musiciens nous étions tous les deux compositeurs poètes
vous  je sais, ce qui est tout à fait normal aussi, il y en a
beaucoup, il y a beaucoup de compositeurs,
beaucoup de poètes et beaucoup de couples qui sont à la fois
artistes et des choses comme ça donc je ne
pensais pas que nous étions si différents
mais certains, d'une manière ou d'une autre, après sa mort, j'ai
pensé que ce n'était pas normal tu sais  ce
n'est pas normal et
euh alors quand je repense à ma vie
oui tu sais il y a certaines choses
assez étranges
euh des choses étranges nous sont arrivées à nous deux
John et moi et
euh maintenant je peux voir que certaines des choses
qui se sont produites dans mon  la vie est assez
extraordinaire mais je refuse quand même de
penser que c'est si extraordinaire
parce que quand j'écoute la vie des gens,
tu sais qu'ils me racontent leur histoire,
quelque chose que chaque vie est si extraordinaire, si
fantastique tu sais et chaque vie est si
unique tu sais et je pense  c'est ça
ce monde est plein de situations uniques
New
York
nous aimerions acheter une île quelque part
et faire en sorte que ce soit un pays
avec des gens du
monde entier et nous cherchions une île
aux Bermudes aux Bahamas  vous savez, là-bas,
vous savez, puis j'ai réalisé, euh,
tout d'un coup, après que cela ait été désigné comme
champ de fraises, j'ai réalisé oh, c'est
l'île que nous recherchions seulement, que nous
cherchions toujours une île dans
l'océan mais cette île, ce n'est pas
obligatoire.  être entouré d'océan c'est
une île c'est l'île que Joan
et moi souhaitions
imaginer qu'il n'y ait pas de
paradis [Musique] Je suis en
dessous [
Musique]
nous au-dessus de nous ciel solitaire [Musique
]
imagine qu'il n'y a pas de
pays [Musique] c'est  Difficile de
[Musique]
faire pour tuer tous
les morts et aucune religion
aussi, imaginez tout le monde
[Musique]
oh
D la vie en
paix toi